it's all they believe in is identity
there's no individual man that's gone
with post-modernism post-modernism is
actually pre modernism resurrected post
modernists are not really interested in
truth the level of irrationality that
grows out of this undermines the
opportunities for doing something really
significant and important this leftist
postmodern Marxist stuff that this is
the new religion show me a post
modernist at 30,000 feet and a jet and
I'll show you a hypocrite if you're a
post modernist just to have a discussion
with someone like you it's cisgendered
male of power you know and white to boot
it's like that's that's an evil act in
and of itself post-modernism has been
identified as a threat to civilization
by people of all sorts of political
persuasions over the years recently most
prominently by Jordan Peterson and other
members of what's become known as the
intellectual dark web
but you Nick Gillespie think that
post-modernism might be useful and is
not all bad from a libertarian
perspective so first what exactly is
your understanding of post-modernism
yeah it you know famously in the 1979
book the postmodern condition by Jean
Francois leotard he defined post
modernism as incredulity toward
meta-narratives which means that you
don't take knowledge or assertions of
knowledge as a given but rather you
understand that knowledge and wisdom and
and even scientific understanding of
things it's not something that you
you're walking around and you discover
in the back yard you stumble across it
like you stumble across the Grand Canyon
or a mountain or something rather it's
something that's produced by humans and
as a result its contingent it's limited
incredulity toward meta-narratives means
that you are skeptical of these big
stories that we tell about well this is
the why the world is the way it is this
is why it's always been that way this is
why it always will be that way or
alternatively this is why the world
should be this way which just happens to
comport with what I want I see that fray
incredulity toward meta-narrative as
very simpatico with libertarianism it's
very simpatico with something like
public choice economics which James
Buchanan and Gordon Tullock the founders
of it called it politics without romance
what it does is it looks at what is
being said why it is being said who
benefits and whether or not it actually
holds up to scrutiny from a kind of 360
degree angle in the zone - political
activity
don't you think on that note see the
treaty King Richard is an institution a
power manipulate represented on the
rigidity not total money la violence
politic this exact same obscure juji's
priestly people in power do tend to act
in their best interests but a tendency
is not an absolute and that's one of the
things that needs to be considered
continually there are no shortage of
flaws in the manner in which we've
structured our society and compared to
any hypothetical utopia it's and I just
absolutely dismal wreck but compared to
the rest of the world and the plight of
other societies throughout the history
of mankind we're doing pretty damn well
and we should be happy to be living in
the society that we're living in so the
first thing that you might want to note
about post-modernism is that it doesn't
have a shred of gratitude Peterson and
other defenders of the classical liberal
tradition say they don't no no no wait
and I'm sorry to interrupt you but
they're not defenders of the classical
liberal tradition Peterson talks much
more about being a conservative which is
not being a classical liberal and I
think that's an important distinction to
make what what he argues at various
points is that you know he seems to be
saying they don't have any gratitude you
know it's first of any cultural critic
from any point of view I love I love the
fact that I was born in the late 20th
century and them living in the 21st
century in the West or what's now you
know what is called the West
that's great does that mean I have some
gratitude for it but I'm not allowed to
interrogate my own culture even he is a
constantly that Western civilization
however you want to define that is in
flux it fails itself it is constantly
falling short of its own
goals its own aspirations its own ideals
this idea that you can't criticize your
own society without unless you show
enough gratitude it's just nonsense
words it's it's culture warrior dumb one
thing you hear along those lines is that
post-modernism leads to moral relativism
where we can't say that one idea or set
of social arrangements is any better
than the other is that a serious
objection I don't think so
particularly there's two things to
consider that one is the idea that
people are somehow disallowed from
disagreeing or from denouncing certain
aspects of the world whether you're a
right wing or a left winger I think the
very existence of social media proves
that's wrong there are attempts at
censorship and whatnot there is no
shortage of people bitching and moaning
about every goddamn choice that
everybody around them makes both big and
small so that's just furious the larger
question and this gets to the
distinction between being a classical
liberal or a libertarian I think of
being a conservative do you believe in
pluralism or not and if so what is your
commitment to saying on things that we
that are very important to each of us we
fundament and 'mentally disagree with
one another how do we live peacefully
with that that is the actual signal
accomplishment of Western civilization
and it came out of religious wars when
people took religion very seriously you
believe in the Pope
I believe in an unmediated access to
Jesus Christ my Lord and Savior where I
believe in this version of Protestant of
Protestantism people used to kill each
other in Europe and in North America
over these questions we don't anymore
that is not moral relativism it's
pluralism and that's the thing that we
need to get back to and understand and
fully appreciate that's the great
achievement of Western civilization if
we're using that term of civilization
that we can disagree on fundamental
things and still live peacefully
side-by-side so how does a postmodernist
embrace pluralism and avoid sliding in
- moral relativism well it depends on
what we're talking about here because
you'll search far and wide for anybody
whether they're a Marxist whether
they're a monarchist whether they're a
postmodernist a liberal or you know a
conservative Republican whatever who
will say like I you know murder and the
rape you know murder and rape of
children or good things or it's no
different than not raping them or not
killing them these these are false
charges there are large broad moral
absolutes that virtually everybody
agrees with pluralism is a world in
which people who believe deeply deeply
deeply in God and they believe in
different conceptions of God and the
stakes are as high as they can possibly
be can get along without killing each
other and can actually gain from talking
to each other and engaging each other in
peaceful commerce in peaceful discussion
and peaceful dialogue and this is where
I think Peterson in particular more than
many people of the you know that kind of
follow him is really great on the issue
of free speech and demanding free speech
particularly on college campuses it is
truly a sad state of affairs that
especially on college campuses of all
places or universities you know speech
is being restricted for reasons that are
not particularly clear or compelling
gravity is not a version of the truth it
is the truth
anybody who doubts it is invited to jump
out of a 10th floor window I think
Richard Dawkins is demonstrating there
why every time he speaks even people who
don't believe in God suddenly want to
worship Jesus Friedrich Hayek in a book
that came out in the early 50s called
the counter-revolution of science
referred to what Dawkins is doing as
scientism taking a kind of understanding
of knowledge the production of knowledge
and the assertion of knowledge and truth
at least with a small T in one area and
then trying to mechanically apply to
other aspects of the love the world
where it just doesn't make any sense to
do that and I think you can see that
Dawkins is right about gravity and that
tells us exactly nothing about what's
the best job to have who should we love
should love among you know same-sex
people be legalized or not it just these
are these are totally different realms
and only a modernist an unreconstructed
modernist would try to claim because we
know physics we know everything about
human activity in human society the
physicist believes that you must be able
to reproduce every intellectual model in
detail that you really must able that's
why I've come to the conclusion to say
that the filter Sciences is the science
of a simple phenomena you as you move
from the physical sciences repair
logically the social science it gets
into more more complex phenomena the
essence of complex phenomena is that you
can explain some principles on which
they work but you never can master all
the data which enter into this complex
phenomena therefore even with perfect
theory does not yet enable you to
predict what's going to happen does
post-modernism undermine productive
conversation by questioning the validity
of you know rationality itself I mean we
work at a place called reason that
purports to believe in you know reasoned
dialogue and without dialogue it seems
like the only recourse you have is
tribalism and that might partially
explain the rise of identity politics
which is what seems to concern Peterson
is post-modernism and productive
dialogue are those two things compatible
yeah I think they're totally compatible
and in fact post-modernism celebrates
the limits of human knowledge not not
that we don't have any knowledge but
that the knowledge we have is constantly
being revised adapted discarded and
expanded and pushed forward so that we
know more but this is something somebody
like Karl Popper who was a very
ideologically akin in many were actually
epistemological II akin to Friedrich
Hayek who is you know a great
libertarian social theorist said that
you know the real truth about science is
that the more we learn or with every new
breakthrough we recognize how little we
really know about other things and we
constantly move forward the discovery of
new problems can be more important it's
into solution
of the problem I think this is perhaps
the most important thing in terms and is
the result of an attitude which does not
go for certainty but goes for where we
fail for the and post-modernism merely
says that our knowledge is contingent
and it's going to change it's going to
evolve and hopefully it's going to get
better it actually is one of the great
four grounds of conversation and of
dialogue if you are a hardcore modernist
meaning that you've figured it out
you're a French revolutionary and
there's a figure that Hayek in
particular attacks in the
counter-revolution of science the
Marquis de Condorcet
who ended up becoming a victim of the
French Revolution but condors say said
you know look we found we figured out
how biology works we figured to have
physics worth math in all of these
Natural Sciences we can apply that to
human society and actually kind of
perfect man speed up the evolution of
society towards perfection that's a
dangerous thing condors say and the
French revolutionaries didn't want to
have dialogues with people because they
already knew what they wanted they move
forward it's really the post modernists
in my experience and particularly in the
way I'm talking about at a libertarian
post-modernism which starts with the
idea that I have my point of view and I
have a hypothesis and it might be
predictive it might be useful it will
become persuasive the more that I am
able to engage you and convince you that
it makes sense and that has something
meaningful and important to say about
how we might go forward and in history
and in our individual lives and people
like Peterson and others like Steven
Pinker view themselves as defenders of
the Enlightenment and I've always viewed
libertarianism and you know the
classical liberalism obviously as a
product of the Enlightenment
so is post-modernism compatible how does
that
where with enlightenment ideas and
values they're you know they're first up
we need to get rid of this idea that
there is the Enlightenment or an
Enlightenment there were multiple
indictments people like David Hume you
know would underscore that in his own
writings so there are many aspects and
the Enlightenment is best understood not
as a you know a single course that a
bunch of really smart people took and
got A's in but it's rather it was a
wide-ranging set of activities and a
shift in mentality and understanding
that was borne out by technological
innovation as well as political
innovation and and social reality and
historical reality people were tired of
killing themselves over which God you
know because of the gods they worshiped
in which God was more powerful or more
right and who which God gave me the
right to force you to live the way that
I wanted to the political achievement of
the Enlightenment is classical
liberalism which is the idea of a
limited government the idea that
individuals matter and that they have
rights that come before government this
is instantiated in in America's founding
documents particularly the the
Declaration of Independence we hold
these rights to be self-evident that we
have you know the right of we you know
we have the right to life liberty and
the pursuit of happiness that's a
powerful statement that is an
Enlightenment statement but it's not the
whole thing and the Enlightenment has to
if you cannot account for if you don't
think the French Revolution every bit as
much as the American Revolution is a
product of the Enlightenment and
enlightenment thinking then you are
merely saying I refuse to take anything
bad you know and associated with the
Enlightenment but the fact is is getting
rid of superstition getting rid of
speaking from authority demanding you
know that we we get rid of the rule of
Kings but then we put in the rule of
science or the rule of a vaguely formed
populace a populace Vox Populi that gets
to dictate what we do you know that's
part of the Enlightenment as well
romanticism with a capital R both as an
aesthetic movement but especially as a
kind of political or philosophical
movement is a reaction to industrialism
but it is also
part and parcel of the Enlightenment as
is you know in in perverted and and dark
forms as is Nazism and the Soviet Union
and the gulag and things like that the
system is systematization of social
organization the idea of various things
like that the Enlightenment has many
many good things in it and many many bad
things in it and if we're not taking
that in the totality and looking at how
these things are intertwined I don't
think we're being serious intellectually
and we're going we're more likely to
fall in to the same problems that we saw
in the 20th century in particular
post-modernism in many ways especially
as it's played out politically is the
new skin that the old Marxism now
inhabits they had to get into the
culture and change the way of people's
thinking through Hollywood and all the
rest of it to create an anti-christian
culture which would destroy the
Christian beliefs and convictions and
the depravity of the people so they
would embrace the ideas of Marxism and
they would embrace the ideas that they
had rejected and they would be opened to
a takeover basically by Marxist so one
theory says that post-modernism is
really the latest evolution of Marxism
which after the after communism failed
all over the world the Marxists decided
we need to undermine Western culture is
post-modernism Marxism in disguise no
and actually back when I was going to
grad school if you like something you
would call it postmodern because you
know you wanted it to be a positive
thing now if you dislike something I
think you tend to call it postmodern one
of the most interesting things about it
about post-modernism and its changing
kind of value in the academic
marketplace in the early 90s Frederick
Jameson
comparative literature and English
literature professor at Duke wrote a
book called post-modernism or the
cultural logic of late capitalism he's a
Marxist scholar so in the early 90s if
you were a Marxist you looked at
post-modernism and you said this is the
cultural logic of late capitalism it
hides the economic
the exploitation that is at the very
center in the foundation of capitalism
postmodern is giving people a kind of
diversion from what they should be
looking at which is the brutal fact of
their own exploitation you flash-forward
twenty-five years later and now it's
right-wingers who are saying that
post-modernism is the ultimate triumph
of Marxism it's a little bit confusing
to me because what drops out of all of
this is the role of the consumer and the
producer in what we're talking about in
any stable definition of what it means
to be postmodern the French post
modernist people like Foucault what was
their relationship like to Marxism both
he and Derrida were seen as antagonistic
to Marxism they were not sufficiently
political or ideological in a way that
for instance celebrated the Soviet Union
or were highly politicized Michele
Foucault was obsessed with the
understanding of power and how power
circulates in a given system and how you
might limit or divert that or spread it
around and decentralize it in this he
follows nobody more closely than
Thomas's who was a psychiatrist a for
decades was a contributing editor to
Reason magazine
nobody he's everybody's idea of a
libertarian in the early 60s
Thomas oz wrote a book called the myth
of mental illness in the early sixties
Michel Foucault published his first book
length worth the birth of the clinic
each of these looked at the ways in
which the medical establishment under
the guise of using helper language we're
gonna help you get well we're gonna help
you solve your mental illness we're
gonna make you feel better we're gonna
banish death and illness under the guise
of that kind of helping positive
language they were actually systems of
social control of getting and taking
people who were problematic in society
casting them as sick and ill and then
removing them from society or
controlling them through the use of you
know it could be physical manipulation
akin to torture it could be drugs it
could be operations all sorts of things
Foucault and saws have many things you
know that they're different about but
they actually also overlap a lot and
this is one of the things when you get
to that incredulity toward
meta-narrative and leotard use to define
you know the the Essen
of post-modernism this is what this is
what post-modernism is it's taking a
whole discourse and asking is it true
does it benefit people does it benefit
people by hiding certain kind of
contradictions or lack of you know
curious lack of persuasion in in its in
its rhetoric or in its in the date of
that exciting to prove it socialism
assumes that all the available knowledge
can be used by a single central
authority it overlooks that the modern
society which I now prefer to call the
extended urban which exceeds the
perception of any individual mind is
based on the utilization of vaguely
dispersed knowledge and once you are
aware that we can achieve that great
utilization of available to resources
and because we utilize the knowledge of
millions of men it becomes clear the
assumption of socialism's as a central
authority command all this knowledge you
detect a postmodern strain in certain
libertarian thinkers notably FA Hyack
what postmodern ideas are most important
to contemporary libertarianism I think
when you think about libertarian ideas
particularly about governance and at any
point when people start to say we know
this to be true so we are going to force
everybody to live this particular way
post-modernism the the distinction
between post-modernism and
libertarianism gets pretty narrow pretty
quickly I think when you look at the
idea of understanding that we all have
partial knowledge of the world
particularly in the social sphere we're
not talking about what what high called
relatively simple systems of knowledge
like chemistry and biology and physics
where there are relatively few variables
that play at any given point and we can
kind of model things and get things
right when you start talking about human
societies and when you're talking about
what high called the extended order
market order where there are millions of
people if not billions of people who
have subjective desires that they want
which change all the time how do you
kind of equilibrate all of that into
something other than mere chaos madness
hostility one of the ways you do that is
by recognizing the limits of your
knowledge rather than demanding that
everybody accede to what you consider to
be the full knowledge of what is right
what is proper what is valuable what is
not and this is also one of the reasons
why Marxist back in the day hated
post-modernism because it was
antithetical to Marxism which believed
that there is an inherent value or an
inherent essence in any given situation
and that that's not subject to flux
that's one of the reasons they hated
capitalism is because they felt like you
know values go up and down in a way that
is it's it's very difficult you can't
plan you can't do this you can't do that
you certainly can't control how people
are going to act and react to things one
of the great things that libertarians
have done Hayek certainly Ludwig von
Mises Milton Friedman Ronald Coase they
they would go back through history and
they would show a lot of the things that
we thought were true actually weren't
and that's also what somebody like
Michel Foucault does he would talk about
in archeology of knowledge rather than a
you know a kind of god-given divine
understanding of everything in the past
archeology implies that we're creating
the past from the future looking
backwards rather than discovering it
like we are you know on an arc on a dig
somewhere where you you brush down
gently and you find the tomb of King Tut
or something like that these are human
creations and we should not mistake the
map that we're drawing for the actual
territory we're trying to describe there
were times where you know people who
would call might call themselves post
modernist or whatever we'd say well you
know science is just another story we
tell it's no different than the Bible
it's no difference then you know it's no
different than it than a bedtime story
and it actually serves the nefarious
ends of a patriarchy or this or that and
we recognize that fully like well you
know
in the Cold War people would look at the
way that the Soviet Union political
prisoners were invariably called
psychiatric patients and they were put
mental institutions but of course that
couldn't happen here because we're an
open society people like saws and
Foucault challenged that in a way that
is very difficult to kind of accept it's
hard but you know growing up there were
all kinds of medical you know truths
that we held to be self-evident go ask
women who went to high school graduated
high school before about 1995 asked them
if they pole-vaulted on the track team
it was a given it was a scientific fact
a medical fact that women just didn't
have the upper body strength to
pole-vault so you didn't have pole
vaulters at the high school in the
college level you do now because it
turns out actually that a lot of the
things that we thought about women in
particular is just false like as a
question of physiology but then there
are other things where it's like well
women you know throughout history and
this is where post-modernism grants the
idea that we're not perfect and that we
make a lot of mistakes and we gain more
knowledge as we move forward through
time rather than truth being revealed
once and for all in some kind of
biblical or religious ecstasy but you
know women for a long time well they
shouldn't have the vote because women
have menstrual periods and that changes
the way they think or maybe it's not
that women can't think so well but it's
they're always trying to you know
they're either trying they're either too
bound to their body or they can abstract
out of certain situations because their
brains are different than men and we
find as we get into more of this stuff
there are real biological differences
obviously between men and women but they
don't always show up the way that we
think and they don't always mean what we
think they mean in social situations and
that's one of the key things and again
to go back to Hayek and the
counter-revolution of science the whole
point isn't that scientific knowledge
doesn't exist and that it doesn't you
know it doesn't work within that sphere
but somewhere and he identifies that as
being in the early 19th century
particularly in continental France
science was taken out of the realm of
the natural research science
says and brought to bear on human
organization that's the primary abuse as
taking science out of its category out
of its realm where it actually was
explanatory and powerful and putting it
into human society where it actually
doesn't do a very good job of helping us
understand society or people what are
the aesthetics of post-modernism and how
do they affect our perception of art and
media what post-modernism does certainly
in TV shows in architecture and art it
kind of celebrates and for grants it's
the creation of meaning rather than kind
of trying to show a perfectly finished
product at the end that seems to have
just come out of nowhere post-modernism
is constantly bringing to the fore the
idea that you are constructing meaning
by watching things The Simpsons is
paradigmatic in this in this case in the
90s this Simpsons is rife with examples
where the TV family is watching a TV
family that's watching a TV family and
they're kind of figuring out how do you
consume this critically how do you
construct meaning what are the tropes
what are the motifs what are the
narrative forms that are used to kind of
make you think something as normal or
natural when in fact it's all weird and
[ __ ] up postmodern art tends to be a
self-aware reflexive what if an entire
QA were in fact pre-scripted to some
degree and what if the interviewer
tipped his hand a bit to the audience at
some point what would that for instance
say about the conversation or about
conversation in general or what would it
say about post-modernism you know I
think it's probably already happened in
this video and it will in every other
conversation that you have everything
you know if we take Rick and Morty and
the multiverse seriously all of this has
already happened and it will continue to
happen in an infinite number of ways and
different times into two equally
possible and possibilities
we're entirely hypothetical but I
thought there were infinite timeline
we're not on any timeline dummy look
my god are those cats I assume they're
Schrodinger's cats they both are and
aren't just like us Mystery Science
Theater 3000 it would show bad movies
and that while three people are one man
and two robots usually it gave running
commentary on it and it allowed again
what it calls attention to is its own
creation and construction of meaning and
of value and of things like that and I
think that's a very useful thing in a
media age in a world where we are
meeting more and more different people
from more and more different places and
more and more different backgrounds
that's a very useful aesthetic to have
how do we create meaning how do we how
do we construct things how do we find
ourselves and define ourselves as
individuals and as groups you know
looking at that I need to kind of take a
quick revision or I want to roll things
back or kind of go in a slightly
different direction about that because
this the points I'm making here actually
remind me of one of the most consistent
blunders I think that critics of
post-modernism make particularly in a
university context when they're talking
about identity politics and you'll hear
this again and again from people who say
post-modernism is bad post-modernism is
evil post-modernism is rotten
post-modernism is the same thing as
identity politics if you're a post
modernist just to have a discussion with
someone like you it's cisgendered male
of power you know and white to boot it's
like that's that's an evil act in and of
itself in fact post-modernism is anti
essentialism it says that there is no
one fact of our lives that totally
defines us intersectionality which
became as a current term in feminism is
actually all about saying we each of us
whoever we are we are the product or the
sum of multiple overlapping oftentimes
contradictory identities communities
backgrounds historical forces and in
order to fully understand things we need
to layer these things on top of one
another to understand exactly where we
are at any given point in time and how
we might interact the the most
productively the most peacefully the
most interestingly and the most humanely
with other peace
people who we don't necessarily
recognize as part of our tribe so in a
two-hour 15 minute debate with sam
harris on the meaning of the word truth
peterson had this to say the Darwinian
view as the american pragmatists
recognized was the truths are always
bounded because we're ignorant and every
action that you undertake its goal
directed has an internal ethic embedded
in it and the ethic is the claim that if
what you do works then it's true enough
there's no reason to assume that our
current scientific view of the world
isn't flawed or incomplete in some
manner that will prove fundamentally
fatal to us is it possible the kind of
post-modernism we're discussing here is
it actually in some ways compatible or
at least informing Peterson's worldview
I mean absolutely what he's talking
about there comes straight out of Hayek
it comes straight out of Karl Popper it
comes straight out of the Enlightenment
which is the one thing we know for sure
is that we don't know so much and you
know that actually comes out of Socrates
so this is a pre-modern understanding of
the limits of human cognition this is
part of what I think needs to be
understood and and accepted by people
particularly on the right but some on
the left who who are anti postmodern
because they think it means that nothing
matters or that there's only nihilism
and that all choices and all discourses
and all forms of knowledge are equally
valid very few people if any actually
believe that you know the only thing
that we can know for sure is that we
know less than we think we know that
doesn't let you off the hook you still
have to act and you still have to move
into the future but you can do it with a
set of policies that are much more
humble and limited so that you're not
dictating other people's lives or how to
live or how to be in the world we've
tried different competing political and
even philosophical ideas of governance
you know from from a kind of liberal to
contemporary liberal point of view where
we control lots and lots of parts of
people's business like
for their public lives or in the
conservative side where we try to
regiment people's personal lives and
things like that
libertarianism precisely because it it
invokes a postmodern understanding of
the limits of human cognition gives us
the space to experiment in all sorts of
different ways to run what John Seward
mill called experiments and living in in
small places where then we see well
what's happening here does this work
does it not work I think that is one of
the fundamental attractions of
libertarianism in the 21st century we
are coming off 250 years of what Steven
Pinker calls you know the Enlightenment
or the Industrial Revolution what Jonah
Goldberg in his recent book calls the
miracle which is this incredible
explosion in standards of living and
possibilities in equality under the law
libertarianism is the philosophy that
has not been tried yet and it's not
simply a political philosophy but it's a
belief in pluralism and a belief in
individualism and voluntary ISM
volunteerism as well as running what
John Stuart Mill called experiments and
living where people are allowed to try
out different ways of living and we all
learn from that and we all kind of pick
off the parts that we like and we
recombine it we hybridize and we
mongrelize it and as long as we don't
force that process too much by saying no
you're not allowed to do that even
though you're not hurting anybody else
you're not allowed to do that because it
offends my sense of what is the good
life or the right life we'll be in a
better place and I think this is where
post-modernism and libertarianism come
together to create a vision of a future
that is open-ended that is innovative
that is increasingly not just
interesting but prosperous both in
literal ways in figurative ways and this
is something where I think a lot of
people who are antagonistic to
post-modernism should go back and they
should read their leotard that they
should read their Foucault but they
especially should read their Hayek if
they want to understand where where this
comes from and the type of world that it
might lead to if the wheel is an
extension of feet
tools of hands back arms the
electromagnetism seems to be in its
technological manifestations an
extension of our nerves and becomes
mainly an information system what
difference is the is the electric
technology making to our interest in
content you cannot cope with vast
amounts of information in the old
fragmentary classified patterns you tend
to go looking for mythic and structural
forms in order to manage such complex
data and moving at very high speeds can
we close out by talking a little bit
about the media landscape the people
we've been talking about here
Peterson Harris some of the members of
what's been called the intellectual dark
web their popularity emerged in the
boundless world of digital media where
you can just speak freely for hours at a
time and people will actually sit there
and listen you know at their own
convenience and it's easy to really dive
deep into someone's head and really
fully understand their perspective is it
a coincidence that discussions about
post-modernism have arisen again in this
fractured but boundless media
environment no I don't think it is a
coincidence I think it's a it's it's a
telling understanding first and foremost
that this conversation which is vital
and important is not taking place on the
on the University campus the university
as an institution is a phenomenon of the
Renaissance and the Reformation and the
Enlightenment it's a modern instant
modernist institution our modern
institution not a post modernist one and
it has become it's always been a
conservative backward looking
institution by design and that's not a
bad thing you don't want to throw
everything out the minute that you think
you have the right theory I mean this
has happened in societies as well as in
university discourses and things like
that it rarely ends well it usually ends
with you know a guillotine slapping down
somebody's neck but universities are not
up for this kind of conversation anymore
and we should not take it as
it's a shame and we probably shouldn't
be supporting universities in the same
way that we might might have once but
the really important thing is not that
it's not happening at the university
which often times seems to be trying to
squash free speech on all sorts of
grounds but rather that it is taking
place and it's taking place in
alternative spaces that simply did not
exist in the same way that the
Enlightenment you know there are
theories of the Enlightenment that the
introduction of caffeinated beverages
and coffee houses where people could get
together without having to hide what
they were talking about but they could
get together and talk about stuff while
there hopped up on caffeine that was a
huge part of how the Enlightenment got
you know got started because you had a
lot of smart people talking about stuff
and building and riffing off of each
other and they have the energy to do it
you know in a different way today what
we're finding is you know the coffee
houses and the the salons are taking
place in alternative media that just
didn't exist in that supplementary space
which is fractured and it can lead to a
lot of bad things a lot of you know you
know when Nazis get together in a beer
hall it doesn't end well but it's also
true that when you know the great
philosophers and and scientists of you
know of 17th 18th 19th century Europe
and North America were able to get
together and just hash things out in a
marketplace of ideas and go deep on what
they cared about it turned out pretty
well so in a weird way we may be
focusing too much on the problems of
universities because they served a
function perhaps they won't ever serve
that function again of being a place of
open-ended inquiry and discourse and
it's said that's migrated into places
that are more amenable to it well yeah I
hope that free and open conversation
just keeps going and I appreciate the
opportunity to have this one with you
for reason I'm Zach Weiss Muller and I'm
Nick Gillespie
you
[Music]
you